Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I didn't press anything, no!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today, we're your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Are you ready?
Are you awake?
BAU BAU!
Thank you for joining us for our 120th episode!
BAU BAU is the 120th episode on the 20th of a Japan time.
In Japan.
How is it the 20th in Japan, huh? 20!
Just a couple minutes ago I was like, how is it the 19th?
The 20th somewhere.
Ruffians, I think more than the majority of you, it's just the 19th.
You have the whole day to get ready for the 20th.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday and Monday aka FUWAMOCO and hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's so funny to see more hashtags than BAU BAUs!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
It's a new week!
I'm so excited!
I couldn't wait to mention!
My understanding of time is very skewed right now.
Because we're gonna be breaking the dimensions, right?
Right!
Cleaning the dimension of time, maybe?
Yeah!
hololive English second concept breaking dimension coming up very soon!
We're so excited for that!
But!
But what?
There's been another Pero Sighting.
If you wanna see what it is.
Okay, well.
De-den!
Pero looks pretty happy here, no?
Well, of course!
You know, because he's all buddy-buddy with the Ruffians, right?
Wake that smile off your face, Pero!
That should be all, Sotty.
Right!
Although, he does kind of look cute so happy like that, you know?
Maybe.
Why Ruffians?
Because you treat him like that, but he's nasty, okay?
He only knows that he can use you for pudding, Ruffians.
Yes, he's just using you for pudding.
Okay.
Don't let him use you like that.
I don't know.
He loves us.
No, he only loves you because you have pudding!
But yeah... He's nasty.
Treat him like he's nasty, okay?
Come on.
But... I don't know what he's making.
Kind of like a smile like this.
Maybe... It's okay to leave him like that.
This just... Right there.
Leave him like that.
Okay, right there.
Right there, okay?
He's not doing anything bad, right?
Yeah!
For now at least.
You don't have pudding.
That's because he's already taken it from you.
You just didn't know.
It's too bad.
But, maybe, maybe, Pero looks like you have a good head pot here, maybe?
Maybe.
BAU BAU!
Be careful, Ruffians.
Be careful, okay?
FUWAMOCO, we have some super happy news for you!
Wow, just at the beginning of the month for our first anniversary, FUWAMOCO, we released our first original song, Born to be BAURO!
And it just reached 400,000 views on YouTube!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
I'm so happy!
Thank you, Ruffians!
I know that probably for a lot of Ruffians and adventricks out there, maybe you've heard it for the first time just the other day.
Yeah, during our 3D debut!
Thank you, Ruffians!
We hope that you like it a lot and that you listen to it many times over!
But for maybe some Ruffians that you're just hearing about this song, FUWAMOCO released an original song today for the first time.
Wow!
We haven't released it today. You just heard about it today.
Well, this song is written by PandaBoY!
He's a composer that's done a bunch of songs for hololive before.
Maybe, you know, Blue Clapper?
But PandaBoY's also written so many songs for our favorite idol groups as well.
So we're really happy that our first official song is PandaBoY's song!
And you know, it's a song that's very active, very funny, dancing, yelling.
FUWAMOCO!
You know, I know that we were talking about originally that we like all the lyrics really all equally.
But recently, I think one of the lyrics that stands out in this song to me is I really like the kimi no zettai mikata BAUDORU desu.
We'll always be on your side.
BAUDORU!
I really like that lyric.
We're rooting for you.
We're always on your side.
We're cheering for you.
We're here for you, Ruffians.
You know it.
Ruffians, please continue to listen to Mocchio!
You like the rap part where Fuwawa is like, no!
The hex time.
I don't know what's rap, really.
Thank you Ruffians!
And I know there's been a lot of Ruffians practicing, you know, we did the hauls before FUWAMOCO Morning and doing our after parties.
Thank you for practicing a lot too!
We hope that you know BAURO is something that we can enjoy lots and lots for many years to come together, Ruffians!
And, you know...
It's a really huge loft to go on.
But you know, one day, we really hope that it can reach one million views.
Yeah.
The Lumina Watchers.
And Ruffians, if you haven't watched the video, go watch it!
It's so cute!
It's so cute.
Super cute!
And we played with low poly FUWAMOCO too!
And amazing illustrations by Sasaki-san!
Yeah!
Please go take a look!
BAU BAU!
You know, just the other day... Advent!
We had our CD collab all together!
BAU BAU!
Did you watch it?
It was such a big day for us!
It was so busy!
What did you think, Ruffians?
It was great!
Perfect!
We're so happy.
We had so much fun all together.
We're just being our normal selves.
But it's always fun all together with Ruffians.
It's just how it is.
The pon-de-ring challenge is over!
They brought out the pon-de-rings for us!
We almost cried because we were so happy to be able to do this!
We have an idea of it when they're like, bring out the kittens!
Right!
And they're like, smash the delicious pon-de-rings given to us!
I don't know, I was just like... We still fought over one, huh?
Yeah, it didn't quite work out.
But it was so much fun.
The donut challenge was really hard though.
We were kind of doing everything on our own, huh?
Everybody else had an easy job.
Team effort.
Shiori kind of helped hold them up in the back, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, and you know we sung Rebellion for the first time.
Yeah!
Sirens too.
What'd you think of the choreography, huh?
Yeah, right?
All for you.
It was so fun being able to dance with all of our friends together!
I really loved the part, you know, I think it's the last chorus when we all turn into the circle and we do the chorus part of Rebellion.
Yeah!
You know we get to all look at each other and smile and stuff.
And you know in Rebellion when we go into the single line we go
I know that I can still be... Yeah, the horizontal line.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that part too is always like... FUWAMOCO, don't cry!
Don't cry!
FUWAMOCO.
And we also used the KINJI letter to add something together!
Yeah, we surprised!
FUWAMOCO, we are so happy because Kimi no Naito Asobi was a song that we used to sing before we even started learning Japanese!
So we were just like... Whatever we thought we'd write.
The song selection is amazing!
I'm so happy!
But Kinjirareta Asobi is such a hard song too.
We really did our best to practice a lot as well.
The sudden zombies too.
Why does it have to be zombies, Ruffians?
I don't know why.
Eyes on me.
I have my own gnome this time!
Gnome!
My gnome!
Oh my god.
I saw, I saw.
You know, some comment later on being, why do they have gnomes?
Excuse me!
It's my gnome!
Hello, my gnome!
That was for my first, like, two club.
Was that our first club altogether?
I think so.
After our debut club.
Yeah.
And Nerissa got so mad at you, Moco-chan.
She's like, get rid of the gnome!
My gnome!
It's my gnome!
Where the gnome comes from, please tick that out too.
It's this gnome, ticked out!
It's so funny!
Mama put Biboo's gnome part too.
Mama put Biboo's gnome part out too, guys.
You know, I think there's a lot of different things to look at on Twitter.
Adventrix, Bijou.
Look at this!
Look at that!
I think you should watch it again because, you know, it's silly things.
You know, Nerissa and I dancing for Rebellion together!
We're in the freestyle part!
It's so much fun!
I don't know what we're doing.
It's too silly.
It's too mean.
It's just like, oh!
It's the worst!
Oh!
Let's do it!
It's just so many silly things like that, you know?
It's sort of funny, cause... It's probably just an us thing.
But, I feel like... There's a lot of pressure on us.
Like, almost like a stress.
Of FUWAMOCO.
Because, you know, I feel like...
Everyone's like, FUWAMOCO!
They're the twins!
I want them to be twins!
I want them to sing!
Yeah, whatever your ideal twin is.
We talked about it before, Ruffians, but...
We don't try to sync.
We just... We just FUWAMOCO!
So I feel like for a 3D debut, there's more pressure because you want to see us sync our movements.
You want to see the twins, you know?
Like you want to see a tiger roar, right?
Yeah, yeah!
It's a tiger, you want to see it roar, right?
Yeah, you want to see the twins sync, right?
But we're not trying to do that so that... No!
The Tigers won!
What was this?
We did the thing that everybody was hoping for!
It wasn't on purpose!
We didn't even know that we did that!
Ruffians, you need to use your brain, okay?
If you think that we're trying to plan when we can think...
That's way too much effort!
No!
You don't have time for that!
If you had a twin, you're like, I'm gonna be the twinnest twin with my twin.
Yeah.
How would you do that?
Where do you start?
You're like, I'm gonna spend a lot of time learning to be the twinnest twin with my twin.
No.
Wait, where do you go?
What do you do?
What's the next step?
I don't know.
Yeah.
No.
Swag.
Yeah.
It doesn't work like that.
We did it, Moco-chan!
We did it!
BAU BAU!
Everyone's happy.
Debut over.
Good.
Yeah.
Is that how it ends, Moco-chan?
Well, you know, I'm happy also you're able to get to the EN stage!
Yeah!
I'm so happy being able to, you know, connect the world and play Parade.
Especially because those are songs that, two songs in particular that really do mean a lot to us, you know.
I just think that we'd be able to sing that all together with Advent on the EN stage for our 3D debut!
Why did the staff have to make sure that the stage is really nice and reflective, FUWAMOCO-chan?
It's so polished.
Why is it always so polished, huh?
Maybe the cell is better in this respect.
Oh, it's not so shiny.
Yeah.
BAU BAU, Ruffians!
Go check out FUWAMOCO's 3D Advent FUWAMOCO debut!
You know there'll be lots of things that we're sure that you haven't noticed much of again.
And see you at our debut too!
FUWAMOCO's 3D debut!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Wow, you know, like we said, it was a whirlwind.
Because, well, there was a bunch of things that we're doing, but FUWAMOCO are unofficial.
World Tour continues!
Maybe some Ruffians already noticed on Twitter, but FUWAMOCO and Advent and Shiori-senpai and Ina-senpai, we're gonna be at Anime Impulse Orange County in California!
USA!
MOFA!
And it's really soon!
It's really soon at the very beginning of September!
The very beginning.
Yeah.
Right!
You bought tickets!
Mama!
Yeah, it's really soon so right now you can apply for meet and greet to be able to meet FUWAMOCO, meet Advent!
Advent-senpai!
Advent, we're gonna have a panel!
Yeah!
Have to look forward to what we do there.
You never know what kind of mischief we're gonna get up into.
You hope you can get a ticket?
I hope so too!
I feel like we've had so many different stops in our unofficial world tour.
And this time, you know, it's in America!
So we hope that you know maybe, Ruffians, if that's nearby to you, that maybe you can come see us!
Maybe you can meet us!
At least, if not us, maybe the rest of our friends.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
A mini Rock n' Rawr Party and we had a meet and greet as well!
It was our first time in Seoul!
We were really nervous.
We were really nervous but there were so many Ruffians!
We were surprised!
We were so surprised!
We were really happy and we were able to meet so many Ruffians in a meet and greet!
Yeah, a lot of Moco-chan cosplayers that are super cute too!
We are so happy!
We're just really happy to be able to talk.
You know, be able to communicate!
You spoke Korean!
Annyeonghaseyo.
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo.
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
That was our best attempt, Ruffians.
I don't even know if it's correct, but we did it, we're Ruffians!
Yeah, our Korean's not very good, but we were happy to be able to go and meet some Ruffians there too, so we had lots of fun.
Hopefully we can go back soon.
We hope, Ruffians, that we can get close to your hometown.
We're gonna do our best as the unofficially unofficial FUWAMOCO World Tour continues.
We're just calling it that.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
I'm not a cat!
I'm a demon dog!
No!
All the cats are cute.
But demon dogs are cute!
BAU BAU.
Demon dogs are not for that.
No no no.
But on the topic of cosplay, there's lots of Moco-chan cosplayers!
Lots of FUWAMOCO cosplayers recently!
Right!
It seems like every single day I see new FUWAMOCO cosplayers on Twitter!
It makes me so happy!
Everyone having fun with their friends, all your passion!
Yeah, you know, taking like little videos together, dancing, and just you know, maybe having like a boat party.
FUWAMOCO Cosplayers.
It's a FUWAMOCO cosplay group!
Can I get your photo?
FUWAMOCO cosplays, maybe they're a little bit shy, but they won't bow back.
Understandable.
Sometimes maybe it's a little bit embarrassing.
A bit overwhelming.
I think her eyes FUWAMOCO-en!
If we can ask.
You don't have to do a loud BAU BAU.
No.
You can do a quiet BAU BAU.
A quiet BAU BAU.
But a friendly.
Yeah, I know you!
BAU BAU.
But that would make us really happy!
So if you know somebody BAU BAUs at you.
Oh, they got super happy!
I know.
They might be shy.
I understand.
And you know, Ruffians, if you see FUWAMOCO cosplayers and you BAU BAU at them and they don't BAU BAU back, that's fine, okay?
You know?
Yeah.
Don't worry about it.
We'll be excited to BAU BAU lots and lots of Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
And other interesting news Ruffians!
This may be a little bit of a silly one, but the hololive homepage has been updated!
The talent page!
Now, all of Advent, instead of being live TV, we are now all there, officially in 3D!
It's just like the other years at FUN!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, we officially are feeling like members of hololive now.
Members, full-fledged members!
Yeah, cause you know, FUWAMOCO has always kinda been a little funny there.
But it really means a lot to us because Ruffians, I don't know if we ever told you, but we remember when we had just debuted.
You know, like just, just, just debuted.
We would just stare at the whole page.
Yeah, at the talent page.
The talent page is like, yeah.
That's me.
That's me there.
I just didn't disbelieve.
And now, what happened?
Why am I here, huh?
And now we're on there.
It's ED!
That feeling's still kind of there, right?
But it means a lot to us.
We're just so happy to be here, Ruffians.
Thank you so, so much!
And you know, FUWAMOCO, we're going to continue to continue to be super ambitious and fluffy and fluffy and reach for the moon in everything we do while also protecting your smile, too.
BAU BAU!
Hi Fuwawa LOL!
Hey!
Well, you know why I'm messing up my words.
Because just earlier today, we just finished streaming Aqua-senpai's Visual Novel Aquarium for over 13 hours.
Yeah, we did it all together, Ruffians!
We finally did it before FUWAMOCO Morning!
13 hours!
I love you say 13 hours, we mean 13 hours!
We took one 5 minute break and one 30 minute break.
Yeah!
You're still sleepy?
BAU BAU!
You're here?
That's amazing though!
Yeah, and Fuwawa, I read a lot, right?
Yeah!
I do my best, but also there's a couple of words that got a little bit funny here and there.
It's difficult and the word wrap wasn't working.
It's a little bit funny.
I was thinking.
But it was such a fun game, really heartwarming, touching, a little bit bittersweet.
But we are so happy to be able to play Aqua-senpai's visual novel because it means so much to us.
It gives respect to Aqua-senpai.
Right now, Ruffians, we have two different
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
No!
It was not!
And the second one after that, to the end, is about 4 hours.
That one's about 4 hours, but that is an archive that will last up until August 28th.
Right now you know special permissions with Aqua-senpai's graduation.
So the second part, the final part of the game, that archive is not gonna stay there forever.
It's just for a few days, okay?
It'll be there until August 28th, JST.
After that,
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
FUWAMOCO, our big big dream is to have our own visual novel come out to produce it too, just like Aqua-senpai did this one.
But when we asked her, you know, why did you want to release a game like this?
She said, you know, she wanted to have something that lasts forever.
And I think that's very beautiful.
Also, hopefully you know, maybe one day we can have something similar just like Aqua-senpai has aquarium too.
We are so happy!
Thank you Ruffians!
It was an intense 13 hours!
But it was so much fun!
We did it!
Thank you!
Please get a good rest soon.
We will too.
BAU BAU!
And next, we have our Doggie of the Day!
Today's Doggie of the Day is... It's Bailey!
Really?
She's so cute!
She's 12!
Yeah!
It's just her birthday just a little while ago.
Happy birthday, baby!
Happy birthday!
Look at that tongue.
And look her eyes.
Yeah.
She's such a cutie.
She's so happy.
And look at the tummy.
I want to rub the tummy.
I want to rub the neck area.
So cute.
How does Bailey BAU BAU?
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Wow.
BAU BAU!
Biou is such a lovely girl.
She might move a little bit slower now, you know.
She just had her first birthday and all.
But that's not stopping her from any walks, you know.
You go Biou!
BAU BAU!
Bailey looks like Garibaldi!
A little bit.
Like a bigger Garibaldi.
Like four Garibaldis together.
Four Garibaldis in one.
That's Bailey.
Well, next.
Ruffians, you've been getting those paws going.
Let's take a look at... Today I went for a walk.
We have De-den!
Today I went on a walk.
Mushroom hunting!
Mushroom hunting together with you!
I'm envious.
It's too bad that you didn't find the mushrooms you wanted.
It's okay, just going on a nice walk in the forest is super nice.
Maybe you found something.
Some other mushrooms!
Maybe some cool sticks or something.
Other stuff.
It looks like you still had a super fun time though.
And you took us along with you too!
I wanna go mushroom hunting.
Yeah, we wanna go!
I wanna go with Senpai.
I don't know if they wanna go.
I don't know if they wanna go either.
But it's a couple months away from now, right?
Fall time is generally the time.
Maybe we can...
Follow in your tracks.
Rope some senpai together with us.
Take them into the woods.
Get some mushrooms.
BAU BAU!
Oh my god, you had such a good time!
Hopefully it was a good experience, right?
Yeah, at least no poison.
And next, we have a Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is... De-den!
Good morning FUWAMOCO!
Good morning!
I have a question for you.
I know you're very good at Japanese.
Thank you.
But I don't know if you have Japanese language certification.
Do you have one?
We do!
We have a Japanese Language Proficiency Test.
JLPT N2.
It's the second highest for maybe some FUWAMOCO fans that aren't so familiar with us.
But we got it many many many many many many many many so long ago that we forgot what it was.
And we just haven't really been able to study seriously or play enough visual novels to kind of just take the final level yet.
Yeah. And you know that taking the N1 is even on our goals list. It's on our goals list!
Yeah!
But it's seriously tricky, Ruffians. It's seriously difficult. Yeah, even, you know, Japanese natives, they have a hard time passing it. So, maybe, we can study together with you, Ruffians. Yeah!
And then, we can pass it all together. One day. Yeah, maybe.
Yeah, everyone. It's hard, yeah.
You have to seriously, seriously study.
You can't just be like, I'm gonna wing it!
No, no, no.
We gotta study.
We have to be serious.
And haven't been serious.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you know, do your best learning Japanese too.
And you know, if you're still an early level, taking the JLPT can always be a really fun way to challenge yourself.
Just try the N5.
But really, don't get all too serious about it.
It's only really helpful once you get down to the N2, N1, N3s.
Otherwise, it should just be a fun activity.
A fun activity to challenge yourself, you know.
It's not that serious.
Do your best, okay, Ruffians?
Okay!
It costs money, yeah.
It costs money.
It's very serious.
Very serious.
Just have fun.
Yeah.
But thank you so much, Ruffians!
Please remember to use the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING to send us your questions, your doggy updates, your Pero Sightings!
Pero Sightings.
And also... Your questions!
They say questions so much.
That was the first thing you said!
You're part of FUWAMOCO Morning, okay?
We're always leading, and I know you wanna be a part of FUWAMOCO Morning, right?
Send stuff.
BAU BAU!
Next, we have another stream coming up not too far from now.
We have... De-den!
We're gonna be doing some chatting!
We have so much to talk about.
Yeah, there's been so many things that have been going on.
We just haven't really had much of a moment to be able to just...
It's been so busy.
So it'll be comfy.
We can read some superchats.
Chat about all these different things.
Listen, I haven't talked about it.
I saved Haachama-senpai.
You don't know how.
You don't know from what.
But I saved her.
Yeah, so maybe we'll chat about that.
Maybe we'll chat about a bunch of different things.
Hopefully you'll join us, hopefully.
BAU BAU!
And a new schedule!
Yeah, look!
Well, you know Moco-chan kinda had a little bit of a migraine.
A little bit of a migraine!
A little bit!
And actually, once Moco-chan's migraine was better, I got a headache.
I don't know how it happened, but it happened.
It happened, okay.
So the Rock n' Rawr Party that we weren't able to do!
Well, we're forcing it into our schedule!
Tuesday!
It's gonna be on Tuesday at 6pm PT.
I hope you can make it on-
We hope that you'll be there, Ruffians!
Because we want to be able to sing together with you no matter what before breaking dimensions!
This is hololive's only song before breaking dimensions!
So we're breaking the schedule and we're putting the Rock n' Rawr Party right in there!
And that's why it's Frog Detective.
What is this game, Frog Detective?
And why is it at 430 in the morning?
It's at 430 AM in the morning because...
We need to become a detective.
A frog detective sounds very cute.
Investigation for the whole bingo.
Frog detective.
So there's some puzzles and it'd be very helpful, Ruffians, if you decided to wake up at 4.30am and help us with the puzzles.
We are not good at puzzles and we need to clear it before FUWAMOCO Morning.
But if you want to sleep, that makes sense too.
And that's why- Oh!
FUWAMOCO's being really silly again!
It makes sense, it's not a mistake.
But then Thursday, we're rushing to get a bunch of homework done!
Because there's so much homework.
Breaking Dimensions!
Friday we have a big rehearsal day!
This Saturday and Sunday we have Breaking Dimensions!
Our first concert!
We need to practice more.
Right.
There's so much to do in Ruffians.
But breaking the mentions is hololive England's second concert!
It's in New York at the King's Theatre for two days!
The 24th and 25th if New York sounds a little bit far for you which makes sense probably for the majority of Ruffians.
You can join us by watching online on SPW and on Sponge!
Or E+, you can get your digital streaming tickets there!
Get your tickets, do not forget!
Don't forget Ruffians!
It's probably not the same now, but you know, in the past sometimes things get overloaded.
So it's better if you buy your ticket in advance.
We recommend getting it early.
And especially, you know, if you want to see FUWAMOCO live in concert on the big stage, that's the number one to make sure you know that you can support us.
The number one thing you can do.
So please, please stay as long as we did to see our concert debut service.
Did you buy it on?
I hope you find out.
Good luck with it!
BAU BAU!
And that's this week coming up.
And for Ruffians who are joining us through the icon today, here is your FUWAMOCO voice!
It's BAU BAU VOLCANS!
BAU BAU!
That's us.
That's us, yeah.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Ankul Floor!
BAU BAU!
Megabots!
A placeholder!
BAU BAU!
She's a kitty.
The Slayer.
BAU BAU!
Park Clown.
Shiro Dog.
BAU BAU!
Moufy.
Bukiri.
BAU BAU!
Shino Ur.
B-N-R-G!
BAU BAU!
To every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
See you soon!